so Handmaid's Tale a hulu series based
off the book from 1985 by Margaret
Atwood which warning you I did not read
so succumb for someone hasn't read the
book but read a bit about the book so I
went to the show blind and let me just
say men need to watch this show from all
my guy friends I've suggested this too
they're always like oh is it girly does
it take place way back in the day like a
Downton Abbey thing which I thought it
would and it does not it takes place in
modern time which makes it so much more
interesting it's not what you think it
is the title does not serve it any
justice this has to be the most intense
show I've watched in years and dark so I
hope more people catch on to it the
Emmys clearly help to get more attention
to it but it still needs that extra push
and it's so impressive because this
series won eight out of thirteen Emmy
nominations and it's the first series
off of a streaming platform to win the
Outstanding Drama Series award so it's a
game changer in the industry for sure
and Elisabeth Moss clearly deserving won
the Lead Actress Award and hand out we
know from leftovers plays Lydia here she
was nominated for Supporting Actress and
won it but Samira Wylie was also
nominated well deserving as well pretty
much everyone in this castle deserving
of getting nominated for something and
the writers and directors and the
cinematographers I watched it after the
award season so I knew about all these
awards I thought save lives up to this
and it completely does it is a acting
powerhouse from left to right everyone
brings it here in the writing the vibe
of the show there is tension the whole
time you're on the edge of your seat
again entitle like this makes you think
it's gonna be boring in a snore but it's
the complete opposite it's the most
suspenseful thing I've watched this year
it had that David Fincher feel to it
we're at a dark tone to it a lot of
blues and greens and it's just creating
anxiety when you're watching it and
what's gonna happen has a sense of
mystery to it got all the ingredients
for great television and it really
doesn't let go and the characters were
framed brilliantly especially Serena joy
this is Weatherford played by Yvonne
Strahovski who I loved from the show
Chuck and IBC if ever saw that she was
the lead actress on that she's a more
goofy show so it was surprising to see
her and show like this and she was
awesome a great villain she almost
reminds me of your classic female Disney
villain it's done so well here she's
such a complicated character and she
played it brilliantly and her scenes are
some of the most enjoyable but to the
framing point of it
every shot had meaning to it and the way
that you portray her where her face
what's mostly be in the corner sometimes
and then with Elizabeth monstas
character offered you were kind of
always getting shots from her
perspective because she was telling the
story so it's also very artistic the
show and it's not in a pretentious way
it's more an a no this makes sense for
the story and this is completely
necessary what put this show above the
rest for me this year was four standout
scenes for me this is stuff that's top
level in history of anything cinematic
so the first scene for me was when
Emily's found out to be in a same-sex
relationship with a Martha she gets
punished for that and they decide the
Martha that she was seeing is gonna get
hung the far away shot from pulling away
in the van from Emily's perspective and
the birds flying by right when Martha
got hung and killed had me at all like
it does not get better than that
and it was heartbreaking horrifying very
very disturbing then I loved the scene
when The Handmaid's are in the dining
hall and they bring in all the kids that
they've created and you realize that the
handmaids are actually gonna be traded
to Mexico and they're watching all these
kids that they made going to these awful
people and the all-star former kids the
kids they just made it's heartbreaking
but the way the whole scene is shot the
lighting the set up everything it
couldn't have been done better and of
course one of the best was in Episode
nine when Janeane is on the bridge with
the baby and she's about to jump those
shots were chilling and there were so
many different angles they took at this
from really far away I'm of day it was
from every character's perspective at
point seeing her I didn't want the
seemed and it was so well done and
offered going and talking to her they
really fooled me cuz I thought she
convinced her to come down and then she
gives her the baby and then Jeannine
jumps but the best scene to me this
season I don't think any scene has ever
made me feel this way I don't even know
how to describe it but when offered is
losing in the backseat of the car and
just screaming her heart out at Serena
joy and calling her all these words and
then saying she's just pure evil oh my
god that was definitely the lock for
Elisabeth Moss winning the Best Actress
Award cuz I have never seen anger
portrayed and full-on hate for someone
so well done toe Lac scene I actually
had a tear coming down my eye but I also
felt like adrenaline and I felt scared
and it was like all these emotions she
was betraying in one feeling that you
were
and she made it perfectly clear where
she was and got out what you were
thinking too so it was so awesome how
they did that and her just trapped in
that car moving around and serene joy
does showing back really not caring made
you hate her so much like that point
you're like I just want her to get
killed
screw her I really could not get enough
me scenes with the commander or Serena
Joy here I thought they were both
perfectly cast
have you seen American Horror Story
Asylum Joseph Fiona's was in that as
well
and he plays that perfect mysterious
type and creepy type he just played the
commander no four no perfect I loved his
relationship with offered and some point
you're like oh he's not that bad of a
guy but then you realize he's a terrible
dude and she needs him going away and
she plays him he's really is the weakest
character in the show and he does that
so well because he's so evil he puts his
foot down but at the same time he's so
weak and really not that big of a threat
and and I can't say enough about Serena
joy I love a good villain and she played
it really well was she's so nice to
offered one moment when it's benefiting
her in a minute it's not she's horrible
to offer it and she played that
convincingly because you can mess that
up you can make that not believable so
it's a very challenging role to do and I
don't think anyone could've done a
better and she's a perfect face for it
to where she's like super pretty but
she's like really not on the inside and
really taller than offered so again cast
him perfectly then you feel bad for her
points because her husband is really bad
too but and you don't because she's
awful too and and her character is so
complicated and you see in the
flashbacks I want to know more about
that because before this all even came
about she was a big proponent of it but
she seemed way more normal so how did
she get this crazy and what is her true
real backstory to become these beliefs
and really be anti-woman when she's a
woman herself so very interesting to say
the least and I hope season 2 they keep
going into her in the commander's
backstory I just really want to know
what the hell goes on Serena Joy's had
the rape scenes here were really hard to
watch Janie was getting raped by that
new commander she had really made you
feel what they were all feeling inside
when she kind of acted it out
he seems like that just felt like the
show that American Horror Story should
have been it's a good version of that
concept where this is a true horror
story this is something that could
happen and it is deep it's heavy not for
the faint of heart this show again the
title not doing it any justice of what
it actually is so I hope this gets to
the right audience had a love Maria
friends character I love that actress -
she was really awesome had great
chemistry with Elizabeth moss it was
really easier for him was that like
strong Rockford moss and it kind of
reversed the roles which was awesome
and they both kind of bring out the best
in each other definitely that girl power
vibe really well done the music choice
here was excellent he didn't use too
much songs that everyone knows they were
just perfect songs for the feel some
modern music as well cuz it is modern
times and the score was really good it
kept that creepy suspense vibe going the
whole time
I would say there wasn't one dud of an
episode very phenomenal first season I
had some down spots particularly the
husband Luke fine his character was a
little vanilla no no for 'no blame the
actor for that but he came off sketchy
to me in the beginning and mysterious
but that never came of anything and you
kind of really see he's just a good guy
so i didn't get why it was portrayed
like that i thought maybe it was a miss
cast here not really sure maybe it was
the actors fault because someone where
the booking con below did it seemed just
like the husband from the book see more
enjoyable in the book i don't know that
was a vibe I got please give me your
pain down below and what really made me
cringe was in the middle of season when
offered sees the carving on the closet
that encourages her that's in Latin the
end of that episode they do that little
montage where she's walking with The
Handmaid's down the street and she's
confident it's that like nasty woman
thing but it's so cheesy and it doesn't
fit the vibe of the show like it steps
out and becomes mean betta know they
just want that to be shared on the
internet that little clip of her and
like people going yeah girl like I don't
that wasn't necessary so it was just
didn't feel like the rest of the show so
I didn't really like that and they did
it again after the stoning scene which
was excellent where they didn't stone
Jeanine and they had again have a shower
she's walking down the road and work
tough very corny I already know she's
tough I know they're tough keep it in
the tone I don't know why they have to
keep doing that and I wasn't crazy about
Moria running all the way from Boston to
Canada that was a little bit of stretch
for me especially because it's like the
middle of winter we don't see how she
gets there alive and eating food and she
really did have any obstacles in the way
that we know if we didn't see like
there's got to be guards she's passing
had she know how to get there exactly
and I don't like that chanted up in
Canada with Luke I think it should have
just been him there because her strength
and season one of the character was her
rebellious attitude towards anything
that came her way and she was really
awesome to watching Gilead and even in
that
housed her in Canada now is gonna take
that part of her away I feel it's gonna
make her more of just trying to save
people down there but she can't be in
the middle of the action which worries
me a bit I'm not crazy about her getting
that and at first I wasn't crazy about
the driver Nick I was worried that he
was your classic hunk no personality
guys chick flick but his backstory hope
changed out a bit and I like the mystery
to him so I got it I got his character
as we went on and he grew on me for sure
and they left on his character great
because he comes and says offered trust
me puts him in the back that's how the
book ends we'll see if it turns out
being the made a group she's gone away
there's someone back but overall I'm
gonna give this season a solid 9 I
really enjoyed it every episode was
great to me as it goes as a whole
compared to other shows at watch this
year it's just above left over season 3
as my top show for the year really AM
for season 2 in April they'll be
covering every episode of that I'm a
little worried about season 2 because
the book has been covered so now we're
going into the show writer territory
let's hope it can live up to this story
here and keep it going interesting I
think they set it up well for future
seasons but you never know so next
season is gonna be a very important
season in telling if this show has legs
or not overall this season was done
excellent it's so enjoyable even as its
own standalone thing so you don't season
2 doesn't talk about that great this
will always be something to go down in
history as an incredible season story
before I go my question for you guys is
who was your favorite character of the
show I'm torn I would say my two
favorites in a tie or janine cuz i love
it for the whole eyeball thing she's
outgoing she's crazy she's interesting
and she's full of every emotion she was
played so well and she's always steals a
scene for me and I of course need to
tell interview I keep talking much for
you Jill of her I thought she was an
awesome villain I'm a sucker for great
villains and she stole the show for me
altogether so she's probably my favorite
by bit so let me know who your favorite
character was down below I'm really sure
to hear this and we can debate it out I
respond to everybody and let me know why
they're your favorite again I'll be
covering every episode of season 2 of
Handmaid's Tale so please subscribe to
do other TV reviews movie reviews
trailer reaction celebrity interviews
you name it follow me at Steve arleigh 1
on Twitter and Instagram for more and
keep coming back